[Musique]
vous pouvez essentiellement
faire ici toutes sortes de courses que vous faites
dans les magasins habituels
aventures vêtements fleurs
articles de sport et matériaux de construction
et
comme ouais presque tout [
Musique]
jusqu'à
[Musique]
nous avons essayé de mesurer la quantité de
déchets réduits dans le chiffre d'affaires donc  depuis que nous avons
ouvert ce magasin ou ce centre commercial, nous avons
réussi à réduire les déchets pour une valeur de
plus de 30 millions de coins suédois
[Musique]
le plus gros effort que nous ayons devant
nous, c'est que
nous avons en commun avec d'autres villes dans
l'ensemble  monde est le
système de transport bien sûr et là vous avez
beaucoup de choses à faire quand il s'agit de
réduire le carbone gsi
[Musique]
vous